tell us why you're at story Expo 2015
today we're at story Expo because we're
looking for storytellers we've spent the
last twenty months building a software
program that breaks down story elements
like people places and things as
essentially Lego bricks of storytelling
and it reassigns them or creates an
interactive story game it's like ebook
meets videogame in the news the name is
called one more story gains and the
software itself is called story stylist
so stylus being the very first writing
implements of man and it's also the most
high-tech implement these days so yeah
and so is this game geared toward people
hoping to write then a story out of
think it's just more for getting
comfortable with words and building
characters things like that you know
what we envision people using it in a
lot of different ways so one way
somebody could use it is to prototype a
film or a video game or a novel and just
use it for their own personal sort of
getting that sense of what that world
looks like or somebody might want to do
a 5 or 10-minute teaser of a webseries
or a novel to say hey listen here's the
world that I've created or if somebody
wants to create a saleable game so maybe
it's 30 minutes long and it gets sold
for a dollar we pay them royalties they
can create content that gets sold
through our distribution channels so
there's a lot of different ways that
storytellers can use our engine and so
it's for desktop and mobile yes so right
now the engine itself story stylus is
available on PCs and we're moving into
Mac development in the next couple of
weeks and so now do you need an
aggregator I'm just thinking of film
distribution and how does it work with
games okay so when you have used the
story set so that when you have used
story stylist to create the your game it
gets displayed on to our web browser
well not our web browser googles and you
know what I mean it gets displayed on to
a web browser and also currently it goes
into Android tablet and we'll be
developing for the iPads as well
so people can play that on multiple
channels and they can also play it on
Facebook in a couple of weeks now you
said briefly when I we were setting up
that people tend to write a lot about
erotic fiction you talk oh okay well I
think a lot of people don't realize that
women make up almost 50% of people who
gain they might not call themselves
gamers so maybe they're playing candy
crush or farm bill or those other kind
of casual social games they also like to
play games that are mystery oriented and
what's more popular are romance
so romance books are actually second
only to children's books so we're also
open to people who want to write
interactive romance and interactive
erotica we think that because you have
people who love books books as books are
about storytelling so why not bring the
casual games and books together and
create interactive story games and
something that's popular like Fifty
Shades series somebody could create that
and do very well for themselves on our
platform so if I'm understanding this
correctly they're creating a game that
becomes like an app is that right sort
of does it kind of lives within our app
so we're gonna be the digital curators
there's a lot of noise in the games
industry right now you have you know
there's so many games that get published
on a daily basis and the app stores are
not curating that content it's just a
flood so we're developing a community of
reviewers and they're the ones that are
going to say you know what this is
really great this needs a little bit of
tweaking this is not believable
so that when you download our app or go
to our website the content that is there
is curated for you and you could say you
know what I spend my dollar I felt
really good about spending that dollar
what is the average engagement time and
I'm probably not using the right word
but in terms of like you know I'm just
singing back to video games you could
maybe go to ten different levels yeah we
envision the most popular web game to be
probably in the 30 minute because people
aren't just like a quick little lunch
bike game you know so they're they're
either playing the game on their lunch
hour or they're playing
just as they're falling asleep at night
they don't want something that's
epically long however if somebody wants
to write an epically long thing they can
or better yet they can use our engine to
create serialized content so maybe in
week one it's three chapters and the
story continues and you're gonna say you
know what I really enjoy that I want to
continue that with that content creator
now you said you do stand-up comedy at
some time in a former life time I was a
stand-up comedian so if you get me after
nine o'clock at night with a few drinks
I may change your perspective on Cookie
Monster forever are there people that do
things that have maybe more a little
more humorous our chasm are they're like
comedy based writings we're fairly new
so we don't have a lot of comedic
content on there right now we've got
some like what do we have we have a
cyberpunk mystery that's coming out we
have a couple of your traditional cosy
mysteries so whodunit I was trying to
convince our writer to do a romantic
comedy of Romeo and Juliet just to show
people that they could have fun with it
it's a pretty classic story and just
wanna have a twist on it you know this
thing where he can never get up the
balcony and she's she doesn't want to be
rescued so I'm looking forward to seeing
what people create with the engine
you